contaminación sobrepesca destrucción de
hábitats calentamiento de aguas los
problemas que enfrenta el océano son
muchos y en francia los asistentes de la
one ocean summer esperan abordarlos la
restauración del océano de lo que está
en juego los océanos están en mal estado
no necesitan pero sobre todo nosotros
los necesitamos los necesitamos porque
son una fuente de oxígeno porque son un
sumidero de carbono los océanos cubren
el 70% de nuestro planeta producen en la
mitad del oxígeno del mundo absorben el
dióxido de carbono desempeñando un papel
crucial en la regulación del clima y son
el hogar de millones de especies pero
también tienen una importancia económica
y geopolítica decisiva la pesca es una
industria mundial de 400 mil millones de
dólares y el 90% de las mercancías
comercializadas se transportan por vía
marítima además aproximadamente un
tercio del petróleo mundial se produce
en alta mar y también en las empresas
mineras muestran un creciente interés
por la exploración en aguas profundas
de minerales actividades humanas que
están llevando a los océanos al límite y
por las que los activistas piden más
regulación y protección y esperan que la
cumbre lo consiga
queremos ver compromisos concretos
actualmente sólo el 3 por ciento de los
hábitats marinos del mundo están
protegidos pero los científicos
recomiendan que protejamos el 30 por
ciento de los hábitats marinos para
seguir obteniendo beneficios sostenibles
de estos ecosistemas sigue de beneficio
físico sistema los conservacionistas
esperan que la cumbre dé un nuevo
impulso a los esfuerzos por finalizar un
tratado jurídicamente vinculante que
proteja las aguas internacionales en
marzo empezará una nueva ronda de
conversaciones de la onu que tendrá como
objetivo concluir este acuerdo